he's not answering any questions that's
okay I have no questions that's right
I'm about to monologue son better make
it quick you only got 8 minutes all
right then let me paint you a picture
I'm Philip a successful periodontist
that's become addicted to diap pan a
said it if I take because I'm junky scum
also for real addiction is a disease I
would be super empathetic if you hadn't
murdered a man what is the point of this
I'll get there so one day I'm working
late when my boss Robert surprises me he
found out I was stealing meds again
junky scum also again not your fault
there's a major genetic component to
addiction he says he's going to file a
police report I could lose my license we
fight and something in me just snaps so
I grab the first thing I can find and I
hit him with it you still have no murder
weapon I do now here's a pick I found on
Yelp of the surgical Suite 6 months ago
and here is a shot that our crime scene
photographer took up the same room 2
weeks after the murder notice any
differences we're not answering that
that's all right I can just tell you
myself the Yelp shot has six of these
heavy Looking Glass awards from the
Brooklyn periodontic Society in the
background whereas this shot only has
five what happened to number six you
murdered Robert with it I you lost all
control and you bludgeoned him to death
there must have been blood everywhere
but you got lucky you were in the
surgical Suite it can be sterilized you
never would have gotten away with it in
your carpeted office that's not what
happened don't say anything more pH and
your office manager would have heard all
of the screaming but she was at her
grandson's play lucky again you put
Robert's body into a wheelchair and
shoved it in the elevator it's a miracle
there wasn't blood everywhere that's not
true now you're in the garage with a
corpse you panicked and left your phone
in your office and you don't have your
car keys but Roberts are in his pocket
so you put him in his car and you take
off you can't believe what you've done
you're flustered you have no GPS so you
just start driving
next thing you know you're in the pine
Barons and it hits you your uncle's
cabin he has a place there you're the
luckiest son of a yes it was you got
lucky at every turn I knew exactly where
I was driving I left my phone in the
office on purpose I was in a surgical
Suite by Design and I didn't use some
glass award that any idiot would clearly
see what's missing I made a rod out of a
special dental polymer killed him with
it then melted it back down it's already
in a patient's mouth
son oh damn oh damn oh damn and that is
three o
dams oh
[Music]
damn I hear you need some help with who
has done this squad meet detective Frank
dilman of the San Francisco PD he is in
town and we were supposed to have lunch
tomorrow but I asked him to come down
because I need an objective set of eyes
on this I can be objective then tell me
how do I look today normal no dilman
bloated thank you dilman is the single
best detective I have ever worked with
sadly he was unjustly fired for
investigating corruption in the NYPD he
hated dirty cops so much they used to
call him Mr Clean I'm sure that's the
only reason they called him that because
I'm bald you think that's funny I
started shaving my head 20 years ago in
solidarity with my mother who was
undergoing chemotherapy oh look I'm so
sorry I'm obviously lying it's classic
male pattern baldness but now based on
your reaction I know every single thing
about you as a person person that can't
be true it is you're cooked all right
let's get started I want written
statements from every witness Personnel
files for the entire Squad of course I
need to have this desk dusted for prints
see if we get a hit on the AFI system
somebody could maybe get rid of those
pigeons of course I need to see any
surveillance video unfortunately this
area is a blind spot the camera that
covers it broke two weeks ago and hasn't
been fixed yet you really don't want me
to see that security footage do you
lieutenant hm I wonder why I was just
stating the facts I didn't do anything
to the camera I never thought you did
but now now I know every single thing
about you as a person everyone back off
dilman has the
[Music]
scene hello I'm your new commanding
officer Captain Seth dozerman my motto
is simple efficiency efficiency
efficiency could probably just say it
once are you making fun of my stutter oh
uh tricked you I don't have a stutter
boom I've already established my
authority through my amazing sense of
humor well done sir welcome to the 99
I'm sorry Sergeant Terry Jeffers and I'm
not interested I have no use for people
I find people weird and confusing I Live
My Life by Numbers you see this watch it
tells me how many calories I burn at any
time question how many calories you
think I burned walking from there to
there you female closest to me oh uh
three
three try 0.8 numnuts I've made promises
to my superiors that I most certainly
cannot keep that's why I need you idiots
to work twice as hard no no no strike
that four times as hard no no no stri
that I need you morons to work eight
times harder than you've ever worked in
your entire life I'm having a heart
attack yeah I'm having a heart attack
get back to work get a doctor holy Moses
he's alive so I want to explain what
happened back there I did not have a
heart attack the doctors have informed
me that I have a genetic heart condition
my aortic valve is 16% too narrow which
um lowers my life expectancy from 100
103 to 64 so sorry sir that's terrible
yes it's depressing they also informed
me that I carry the gene for web feet
which just interesting more than
anything else but um when you stare
death in the
face as I have it really puts things
into perspective namely that I've been
wasting too much of my time farting
around so that stops now say goodbye to
the fun hilarious laidback Seth dozerman
that you used to love
boys hand them out the hell are these
what the hell are these These are Dozer
pads each one is equipped with a GPS
system and a countdown clock to remind
you to complete a task every 55 minutes
it also has B gamon on it which I could
not delete but you are not allowed to
play What happens when the clock Runs
Out failure failure you are behind
schedule oh that's fun yeah your 55
minutes starts
right
now
you two have been in this evidence
Locker for NY what nothing nothing you
were just making out with
Peralta there's that candy bar wrapper I
was looking for oh Santiago what are you
doing here so I guess it is H before
chose with you friend now I understand
why nothing gets done in this Precinct
the detectives are too busy Frenching
with each other you know what your
little honeymoon is over cuz as long as
I'm here you two are done and I'm going
to be here a long long long
long long long long
long oh this is a heart attack this
right here this is a heart attack ooh
it's a big one ooh
o I'm going to get help sir it's all
right we're getting help tell my wife
then I love her work ethic Case Closed
Justice served Peralta amazing oh
God Charles Charles
your ex-wife is here Elanor the
destroyer of worlds why maybe it's
nothing bad maybe some of your mail got
sent to her house oh God I hope not if
that happened she would be livid ow well
just don't assume the worst that's all
I'm saying don't why did you bring up
the mail thing I
don't Hello chunk heard you want your
sperm you're going to have to go through
me oh no this is way worse than the male
thing what mail thing nothing there's no
mail thing there's no mail thing but
it's my sperm how did you even find out
I wanted it because it counts under my
name storage facility called me saying
that you were looking to make a
withdrawal so I went ahead and withdrew
it for you I have all of your spur but
you don't even care about it Elanor I
mean remember oh hey Charles I'll never
have a baby with you because I don't
love you and a child's not going to fix
that o when we started doing the silly
voice I thought it was going to be more
fun but wasn't I do not want your DNA I
want something else I hit some dumb ass
with my car now he's suing me what I
want is is for you to use your badge and
your gun to intimidate him into dropping
the case wow that is so very illegal
he's not doing that I don't care you
have 48 hours to do so or I'm going to
take your sperm and I'm going to dump it
into the East River please don't do that
and there will never be the possibility
of a little
pie-faced Charles Bole Jor proud of it
it's me all right remember this is a
negotiation we can't let her know how
badly you want this Jake what if she
destroys the sperm she's not going to do
that Charles because then she'd have no
leverage all right you know this they
never shoot the
hostage hey do you threaten that
9-year-old man for me yet but the guy
you hit was 90 yeah and you would know
that if you had talked to him which
obviously you did not so goodbye no no
no wait wait wait look we can't help you
out until we know that you actually have
the samples we need proof of life I'd be
happy to dump one of the containers out
of the window no no no no don't do that
please don't dump my sperm on us hello
ma'am top of the morning to you sir this
was a real hack job hi Mark T he plays
to take a cold tracker on the show yeah
he does and if I know cold tracker the
next thing you're going to say is so so
what's it going to be rock paper
scissors or gun you watch the show I
like that so get me up to speed who's
been in here since the incident what's
he doing oh I think he must be one of
those actors who has to stay in
character all the time I heard Dustin
Hoffman did this on the set of Tootsie
and everyone hated it oh no he just
thinks he's a detective because he's
been playing one for 15 years I can hear
you oh look at the time well they need
you on the set Cassie I'll walk you
over ooh has anyone noticed this crumb
you might want to bag that s the boys at
the lab and what have we here whoa whoa
whoa don't touch that isn't this the
case the laptop was in yes but in real
life when we handle evidence we got to
wear gloves never wear gloves on the
show fans will love to see my fingers
almost as much as they love seeing my
feet Google it no Sarah what's the
status on the toilet seat heater for my
trailer it's day for a cold butt cheeks
going on over here I'm sorry but this is
Official Police business you putting
this scuer I got
this Sarah you're a PA what do you make
a year2 $300,000 30 $300,000 a year
30,000
oh
that